Avery Kim: Today’s focus: CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Riley Chen: Any blockers from last time?
Jordan Patel: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Avery Kim: Risk: scope creep for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Priya Singh: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Riley Chen: From QA perspective, Specifically for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Noah Williams: My take is we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: My take is we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Samira López: I think we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; start with a spike.
Jordan Patel: I think we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Risk: flaky tests for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Avery Kim: UX needs a final pass on CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Priya Singh: Infra-wise, We might need a migration.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; start with a spike.
Jordan Patel: Infra-wise, Specifically for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Priya Singh: Action: write migration.
Avery Kim: Let’s capture action items clearly on CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Avery Kim: Action: book design review.
Avery Kim: I propose we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; parallelize testing.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Jordan Patel: Risk: accessibility gaps for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Samira López: I think we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Samira López: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Noah Williams: Action: write migration.
Samira López: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: From QA perspective, We need to align with capacity.
Jordan Patel: Action: create test plan.
Avery Kim: Risk: scope creep for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Priya Singh: Infra-wise, We might need a migration.
Riley Chen: My take is we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; ship a thin slice.
Riley Chen: From design side, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Samira López: Risk: accessibility gaps for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Priya Singh: From QA perspective, We should add a feature flag.
Samira López: Action: set up dashboards.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Jordan Patel: From design side, Let’s capture action items clearly.
Priya Singh: Observability dashboards for errors on CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Priya Singh: Action: create test plan.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; start with a spike.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; parallelize testing.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; start with a spike.
Samira López: Action: write migration.
Samira López: Let’s not block on CI/CD pipeline speedup; start with a spike.
Priya Singh: Risk: scope creep for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Avery Kim: Risk: accessibility gaps for CI/CD pipeline speedup.
Samira López: I think we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: My take is we split CI/CD pipeline speedup into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Okay, who can take ownership?
Avery Kim: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Priya Singh: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.